[Music]
hello there good evening you're watching
the press preview it's a first look at
what is on the front pages as they
arrive into us here well it's time to
see what is making the headlines with
the journalist and the broadcaster jenny
clement and the pr consultant alex dean
they're going to be with us from now
until just before midnight so let's see
what is indeed on some of those front
pages well the mirror reacts to the
verdict in the so-called waggata
christie libel trial with the headline
win
rooney
you get it yeah now the start is rebecca
vardy declaring you're not singing
anymore
not quite sure what that's referring to
anyway the sun highlights the two
women's differing responses
to the verdict
according to the eye liz truss's lead in
the polls over rishi sunak has widened
as it appears mr sunak's change of heart
on tax cuts hasn't helped him gain any
ground
sunac suffers new blow proclaims the
times with word that his opponent has
been endorsed by the former leadership
contender tom tugenhardt
and the guardian says mr sunak will now
try to revive his fortunes by shifting
his emphasis to so-called culture war
issues and attacking left-wing agitators
and the express focuses on proposals by
mistrust to change mortgage rules that's
with the aim of opening up home
ownership to more people
while the telegraph says that she's
planning what the paper calls a
thatcherite shake-up at the treasury
and the mail leads with the looming
hosepipe ban now that could affect up to
17 million people
and the financial times carries warnings
from the head of the confederation of
british industry that uk businesses are
choosing to cut their ties with china
and that may inadvertently be making the
cost of living crisis worse
what a reminder that by scanning the qr
code that you'll see on the screen
during the program you can check out
those front pages of tomorrow's papers
while you watch us sit and talk about
them well as i was saying we're joined
tonight we have the great pleasure we
are joined by jenny clement and alex
dean uh very good to have you both uh
back with us here on sky news uh always
a pleasure as i was saying um
there's an awful lot of wangatha
christie all over the front pages but
before we get into that before
before i indulge us in that uh
pleasurable journey we do need to talk
about some politics don't we big story
on the front page of the times alex and
liz trust has gained a pretty prominent
backer
yeah it feels like
a couple of significant moments in a row
ben wallace announcing in favor of liz
trust i'm not just uh announcing that he
supported her but uh going into some
quite punchy details why yesterday and
now tom tookenhack uh doing the same i
think that um
you know this is a contest that's still
got a month to run uh things can happen
things can go wrong for a campaign but
it really does feel like it's done now
um liz trust has gained support across
the board uh people would not have
expected tom tuggenhack to have endorsed
liz trust they would have thought he was
a natural stablemate uh for rishi sunak
and this is just another nail i think in
the sunac coffin i really feel for his
campaign right now they're not just on
the back foot they must feel like they
are some way behind
and i know there's a bit of way to go um
you could never write off the second
option in a binary contest we've seen
that in a number of electoral positions
but right now it does feel like this is
liz trusses doesn't it yeah well that's
certainly what the eye is saying they're
saying a liz trusts heads
for number 10 as soon as tax u-turn
fails jenny
uh yes and it's extraordinary isn't it
cast your mind back a few weeks uh rishi
tsunak was the establishment candidate
uh he was the clear front runner among
mps uh he had the backing of so many
tory whips former bigwigs this is
incredibly uh damaging this uh these the
way that the the the campaign has been
going for him he he had everything to
lose and he seems to have been losing it
although as alex says we've got five
more weeks to go of this i'm not sure
how much more we can take but um this
poll is very interesting it says that uh
sunak is is uh failing to make ground uh
but the does the public say neither
uh he nor uh
nor
uh trust would win against starmah in in
a in a general election and um you know
that that can't be very heartening for
the tory party members who are going to
be voting at the moment i mean i think
the the uh endorsement of tom tugan is
particularly interesting because both he
and ben wallace are very popular uh
among two party members uh
he's one nation isn't he's what they
call the one nation tory
uh and so if if she's got
as well as ben wallace it's very
significant what's happened with rishi's
tsunaks campaign do you think alex
because i mean he see everything seemed
so slick it was like he could do
certainly in his in his days as
chancellor before he was actively
actively campaigning for the pm's job he
had a very slick uh sort of team behind
him didn't he very slick social media
and now it seems that every time he pops
up and he went alone didn't he tonight
with andrew neal liz trust was
celebrating her wedding anniversary um
but it feels like every time he opens
himself up to some kind of media
performance media scrutiny the bookies
lengthen his odds of being pm
well i think that supposed slickness is
part of his problem i think that liz
trusts has
quite adeptly made a a a positive of her
supposed um unvarnished approach and she
made a virtue of the fact that she may
not be the best presenter but that she's
sincere and authentic and certainly
polls of conservative party members that
which is run by conservative home and so
forth suggest that that message has
really come through i think there's a
couple of other things about the sunak
campaign that have led it to difficulty
the first
is that
he's had some very bad luck uh with the
timing of these things the allegations
against rishi soon after the issues
about his tax arrangements and and so
forth if they'd been a year ago uh he
might have been able to brush them off
by the time of a campaign if they were a
year from now then it would have been
once he might have done much better in a
campaign but instead here he is whilst
they are still fresh in the mind and i
think especially tory members don't like
the fact that he tried to hang on to a
green card a kind of insurance policy
which meant you could go abroad if your
political career didn't work out and i
think the second thing that hasn't
really helped sunak in the course of uh
his endeavors against uh liz trust is
that um there's been a momentum of
people backing trust she's gone from uh
being quite some way behind right she
wasn't even second at one point you know
she she just she gained endorsement
after endorsement and as we saw bad
enoch go and braverman go and mordent go
uh she's gained more and more
endorsements no one would have expected
tonight to endorse uh trust i think and
the ben wallace
endorsement seems quite a significant
one those things taken together are
really hard for a campaign i imagine
they'll be having a couple of stiff
drinks tonight and trying to
regroup
yeah well um john craig our our politics
correspondent was saying that liz trust
is going to be opening the champagne
she's celebrating her anniversary with
her husband but we'll also probably be
celebrating rishi sunak's performance on
andrew neal and the front page of the
guardian jenny says we've got a treat in
store because the desperate rishi sunak
campaign is going to try and revive his
chances by wading into culture war
issues
i would say in rishi st next defense at
least he he went on andrew neal and uh
you know he did he did quite decently on
that i think his biggest problem is that
you know he does not like criticism and
he does answer questions that are
critical of him with a sort of indignant
disbelief that anyone could ever
question uh his his his record that
doesn't go down very well i don't think
but yes this front page of the guardian
god this is depressing this idea that
he's going to try and revive his
campaign by uh dipping his tone to the
culture wars and talking about how you
know leftists bulldozing british values
talking about woke nonsense and the
pulling down of statues this is the
stuff of two years ago of the black
lives matter protest it's really
depressing if you think that this is
what conservative party uh members are
crying out for the country is actually
crying out for vision and insight and
leadership the rest of the front pages
that do talk about the leadership debate
they are full of liz truss's initiatives
to do with mortgages to do with uh
the the uh removing the freeze on on new
grammar schools regardless of what you
think at least these are actual uh
policies and he should give conservative
party members more credit i would say
nobody wants to be you know
indulging in this uh level of debate i
think both of them are trying to cast
themselves as the chippy outsider here
that's what's so funny even though both
of them have been in cabinet positions
for a very uh long time and both of them
are trying to set themselves up as the
underdog list trust because she doesn't
come from privilege because she wasn't
tipped for greatness in the same way
that rishi sunak is him uh having such
odds against him at the moment he's
going to be you know really digging down
on that of saying you know i'm now uh
the outsider vote for me i i'm i'm i've
got uh you know everybody loves an
underdog in this country but he's going
to have to come up with some real ideas
and some real policies because this
country is in a cost of living crisis we
really want to see real vision and
leadership and much much more than just
cultural push okay well the clock is
against us i'm afraid so we're up
against uh the break but when we come
back we've got uh all the fun in store
for us because we can get our teeth into
the wagata christie verdict can't we uh
thank you very much both of you see
again in a minute um and also we can
talk about the hosepipe ban that comes
into effect in parts of england we're
going to be discussing the wider
implications of that as well when we
come back
[Music]
you're watching the press preview uh
with me again jenny clement and alex
dean now we have now the pleasure of
talking what's on a number of the front
pages of the tabloids of course the
verdict of the wagga christy trial has
captured
the nation hasn't it in many ways um in
football parlance jenny a spectacular
own goal for rebecca vardy
yeah you you've just nicked my only
football-related pun
it's mine too i'll have to fair it uh
it was a completely damning judgment uh
they said the judge said that rebecca
vardy's uh testimony was evasive
and unreliable uh it was a 75-page
ruling and you know what i normally read
these rulings that's my idea of fun but
i just couldn't couldn't stomach it what
a waste of time and money colleen rooney
said as much in her statement today they
tried to she tried to settle it four
times out of court but rebecca vardy was
determined to press on no doubt
encouraged uh by her lawyers somebody
should have said no to her uh there are
going to be enormous legal costs for her
three million pounds it's estimated
because she has to pay uh her own costs
and and a huge chunk of of colleen
rooney's and that's not gonna be nothing
to her we think of footballers and
footballers wives as being
incredibly rich but three million pounds
is not nothing it's an enormous uh
amount of money uh and
just why what incredible self-harm this
was but this verdict is a victory uh for
common sense uh we could all uh see that
they should never have gone to court in
the first place incredible act of
self-harm and the thing is
in some respects uh you know there are
lots of people saying she's damaged her
reputation irreparably but i think maybe
she's got what she wanted which was
attention
yeah country loves a redemptive story as
well um alex just quickly before we talk
about hose pipes um were you remotely
interested in this at all
oh i was gripped uh by this i think that
many of us were i got about halfway
through the judgment so i did a bit
better than jenny but i confess i
couldn't finish it because it was so um
obvious as jenny says i thought that she
should never have
come to court i think vardy was very ill
advised to pursue it i thought the phone
in the north sea stuff from her agent
was
very unattractive i thought that the
arguments offered by vardy in court it
didn't go down well at all well and i
thought that
colleen rooney was palpable i mean she
did an amazing thing right the sting was
very good and i think that most of us
look at that and say that was quite
smart yeah now rebecca vardy's saying
the judge has got it wrong so uh she's
doubling down there
let's talk about as if the good times
will never end let's talk about hose
pipe bands jenny
apparently 17 million of us are facing
one there's there's a million people
already officially facing one in new
hampshire and the isle of wight we knew
this was coming didn't we uh papers all
this week have been saying this has been
the driest july since 1911. surely it
makes sense that we shouldn't be
watering our lawns however there is a
point to make which is water companies
have a very bad record when it comes to
mending burst pipes how many of us have
walked down our local high streets and
seen them gushing with water they need
to do better when it comes to wastage
but i mean surely any of us can can can
look outside and see that there is a
water shorted well not to shower uh so
much last week we've got to do what we
have to do yeah we can see plenty more
of those coming in as well can't we um i
had wanted to bring you in there alex
but we are out of time